breaking news from the Middle East where
a US drone strike killed one of Iran's
most powerful military leaders overnight
the targeted killing of major-general
Qasem Soleimani inside Iraq is a
dramatic escalation in the confrontation
between the u.s. and Iran video
apparently from the aftermath shows
burning wreckage near Baghdad's Airport
Soleimani led the powerful Kuhns force
of the Islamic Revolutionary Guards
blamed for killing hundreds of American
troops Iran vows a harsh response Iran's
supreme leader tweeted quote severe
revenge awaits the criminals who carried
out the strike this drone strike signals
a new u.s. military approach to Iranian
threats yesterday a statement by
President Trump's defense secretary mark
espera seemed to foreshadow the attack
he said quote we will take pre-emptive
action as well to protect American
forces to protect American lives the
game has changed end quote we have a
team of correspondents in the Middle
East and at home covering every major
angle including Iran's potential
military response the White House
strategy and the growing controversy in
Congress and we're gonna begin with
David Martin at the Pentagon for us
David good morning so what's at stake
here
well this opens a dangerous new chapter
in the long-running confrontation
between the u.s. and Iran the drone
strike eliminated a key enemy but it
could also put Americans throughout the
Middle East at greater risk
awesome Suleiman Eva Iran's state
television confirmed general Qasem
Soleimani death overnight was a deputy
commander of iranian-backed militias abu
mahdi al Mohandas a close advisor to
sulemani who was sanctioned by the u.s.
for violence against americans was also
killed unverified video from the scene
near Baghdad International Airport shows
the wreckage of two vehicles President
Trump
authorized the Thursday air strike as
part of his maximum pressure campaign
which has intensified in recent months
in a statement the Pentagon blamed
sulemani for the deaths of hundreds of
American servicemembers
writing he was actively developing plans
to attack American diplomats and
servicemembers in Iraq and throughout
the region the u.s. blames sulemani for
orchestrating the rocket attack on an
Iraqi military base that killed an
American contractor last month and for
approving the attack on the US Embassy
in Baghdad earlier this week
retired General David Petraeus who
commanded American forces during the war
in Iraq called sulemani our most
significant and evil adversary in the
greater Middle East seen as a terrorist
in the US sulemani was respected in Iran
and tried to reshape its influence in
the region he had the backing of Iran's
supreme leader and was the head of the
Iranian Revolutionary Guards codes force
a u.s. designated terrorist organization
that armed and trained Iraqi Shiite
militias responsible for killing US
troops enough is enough
earlier in the day defense secretary
Mark espera said Iran may be planning
new attacks against the US and that the
game has changed this is part of Iran's
malign behavior that they've been
spreading across the region from Africa
all the way through the Middle East into
Afghanistan now for 40 years and it's
this type of bad behavior that simply
needs to end President Trump warned
earlier this week Iran would pay a price
but he did not want war I don't think
that would be a good idea
do I want to know I want to have peace I
like peace the u.s. military throughout
the Middle East has been ordered to
hunker down and be ready for Iranian
retaliation Jericka David Martin force
in at the Pentagon
you